[Music]
this weekend we had the 40th anniversary
of the greatest sports upset ever when
the US Olympic team beat the Russians in
hockey up to then the Red Army team had
won the previous four gold medals dating
back to 1960 the last time a US team won
gold as a kid you can remember sitting
in front of a TV transfixed witnessing
history and for me my first complete
hockey game but you have to wonder where
Bernie Sanders was back then and who he
was rooting for here's Bernie from the
eighties it's amazing anyway that was a
long time ago but you might consider how
Soviet citizens felt when they heard a
free person in a free country papering
over their misery doing publicity for
their dictator so has Bernie changed
much
has he learned not to minimize the
tragedies of totalitarianism here he was
on 60 minutes last night very opposed to
the authoritarian nature of Cuba but you
know you guys it's unfair to simply say
everything is bad you know when Fidel
Castro came into office you know what he
did he had a massive literacy program is
that a bad thing
even though Fidel Castro did he yes the
literacy program the old joke the left
always waves when you bring up the
ravages of communism but everyone can
read they'll say yep and Ted Bundy was a
great dancer and Charles Manson played
decent guitar but I will give Bernie
this admitting Castro did bad things
that's progress or at least a concession
to the obvious so as Bernie storms
towards the nomination remember history
the good and the bad and remember what
side Bernie chose murderous tyrants is
that a bad thing even though a leading
Democratic candidate did it the answer
damn straight it's bad Bernie's now into
his eighth decade he's had a long adult
life to reconsider and he still can't
get it straight welcome back Hwan good
to see you good to be here isn't it
great to be back
you were you were to touring Disney and
and Universal Studios and now you're
back with the adults I was in the home
of kiddie capitalism my wallets lighter
because of kiddie capitalism
I want to ask you that I think this is a
fair comparison the weakness of the
right is a desire to export values to
countries but the weakness of the left
is always to romance any radical
movement right it's like there it's like
no matter if it's if it's Cuba if it's
if it's Soviet Union or El Salvador
Nicaragua it's like they they've never
met a revolutionary cause that they
didn't like it isn't that that kind of
that kind of weakness that Bernie kind
of expresses maybe yeah I think that's
right I mean that the problem at the
moment is I think there are people both
on the left and the right who don't
understand how popular Bernie's rhetoric
is this is a shock to me because I'm one
of those people didn't realize it but I
mean the fact is there's some people let
me just think about certain but people
I'd say facing mounting medical bills
they don't care if Bernie Sanders says
oh yeah Fidel Castro went that bad or
they don't care if Bernie Sanders says I
don't know how I'm gonna pay for it they
just think wait a minute my medical
bills are overwhelming I've got problems
in my personal life and I see it through
my prism and Bernie Sanders say this is
going to help me so I think this is the
populist appeal that Trump had from the
right I think this is the populist
appeal from the left we live in a
populist political era that's true and
this is we've talked about it this is
could be the mirror of Trump we do have
tape of Bernie talking about how much
his programs will cost from 60 minutes
let's play that yay
do you have a price tag for all that we
do I mean you know and and the price tag
is it will be substantially less than
letting the current system go I think
it's about 30 trillion that's just for
Medicare fraud so you have a price tag
for all of these you know why don't we
try to know you've mentioned making
public colleges and universities
tuition-free and canceling all student
debt that's correct that's what I want
to do we pay for that through a modest
tax on Wall Street speculation but you
say you don't know what the total price
is but you know how it's gonna be paid
for how do you know it's gonna be paid
for if you don't know how much the price
is marching you know I can't rattle off
the or every nickel and every dime Dana
that no one can
that's a fact and today he also
announced a 1.5 trillion dollar program
for child care so this is that is truly
cradle to grave yes it is beginning the
revolution the revolution like that it
is intoxicating
and I think though just things
strategically for a moment he's got to
win Florida if he wants to win the
presidency and that's a that's a 50/50
proposition for them probably I mean I
think Trump's got the edge of course but
you have somebody like Democratic
congresswoman Donna shillelagh who
represents Miami who comes out today on
the fetal castro piece and was like oh
no that's that is that is not going to
fly with us down here and another
congresswoman down there did the same
both Democrats I think that the Bernie
versus Trump matchup could actually
change the way we looked at the
electoral map maybe it won't but I think
that it will and what's it really
interesting is going around I was in
Colorado over the weekend and they
passed the legislature there passed one
of those national popular vote things
where no matter who won in their state
they would pledge all their delegates to
whoever won the national popular vote
but think like what if President Trump
wins the popular vote because of this
then all of that effort for the on the
Left will have been for nothing and
they're trying to change a system for no
reason
yeah hmm Wow Trump winning the popular
vote there goes that talking point long
wait till that happens you know what I
just realized one if bernie is the
nominee is gonna have to defend Bernie
Sanders for nine ones that's gonna be
difficult it's gonna change the whole
dynamic of the fire what to think of
that about the literacy program Greg yes
they weren't teaching kids how to read
Hemingway and how to use an adverb this
was a propaganda effort they were having
them read Karl Marx yeah that was the
literacy read the communist manifesto
and then the other thing he praises the
health care Fidel had three botched
surgeries in his country by Cuban
doctors they had to send out to a
surgeon in Spain to come back and try to
save his life but he died I don't know
how they're gonna get around him
praising Soviet Union Castro Hugo Chavez
when Bernie needs seniors to vote for
more than blacks because seniors
remember the Cold War they have money in
the markets maybe they own a business
they won't vote for a Republican but
they are not going to vote for a
revolution and that's what Bernie wants
my mom told me she will not vote for
Bernie Sanders she's voting for Trump no
but she will not vote for Bernie because
this is a direct quote Bernie can't pay
for anything it doesn't add up she also
doesn't like being yelled at but to your
point not by me but by Bernie to your
point one Bernie does make people feel
like he cares about them workers feel
like Bernie cares and in an election
that is a big positive piece of empathy
that you can really come out and vote
for someone based on it's the same thing
with Trump though that trumpet they felt
that Trump was connecting with the
voters the average person and that's
important dagan I do credit Sanders I
will say this that off the bat he
admitted Cuba Castro and Cuba did bad
things I mean that to me is like a
little bit of growth no he's just gotten
better it's soft-pedaling his support
for murdering dictators yeah
and leftist to use your word
Tyra's he's just better at trying to get
people to ignore it if you go through
the list
you said Hugo Chavez he wrote a letter
in January of this guy who starved his
own people these are individuals who
killed their own people either
intentionally or accidentally he
supported the Socialist Workers Party
presidential nominee in 1980 and 84 he
supported soviet-backed leader Daniel
Ortega on a trip calling him impressive
and saying it makes sense for the regime
to suppress newspapers he advocated a
100 percent tax on anybody making more
on earnings more than a million dollars
he has asserted as recently as 87 total
takeover by the government of giant
swaths of the economy of industries and
the reason seniors won't vote for him
because Medicare for all not only wipes
away a hundred and eighty million
people's private insurance who get it
through their employer it also folds
Medicare it is exists today into his
plan it gets rid of Medicare as it
exists today try to sell
at to somebody who's over the age I
think I remembered 2016 we sat around we
said you know Trump said this Trump did
this Trump Trump changed his opinion on
this abortion music Democrat and you
know what guys president stronger but
he's running on taking health insurance
away from individuals currently
one-third of Americans in Medicare and
four fifths of those in Medicaid get
their benefits through a private
insurance company this is today so the
only the only argument that the left has
if Bernie gets the nomination is boy he
might not do it yeah well they if they
lose his House and Senate he won't be
able to do it